oh and here's and by the way I am
concerned that like Trump Trump is ism
is a boy that like like when he's in
there with kim jeong-hoon and they're
getting along real well
that worries me yeah it doesn't worry
his supporters they think it's great
right they think it's phenomenal yeah
yeah that kim jeong-hoon a guy who
tortured that poor kid otto warmbier
remember that guy hmm i don't wanna be a
was this guy who supposedly was on some
school trip or whatever and he like
stole a flag has a choke in north korea
oh right yeah i heard about those than
all these people on Twitter or like well
that's white male privilege you stupid
white bet like he's being tortured yeah
in a labor camp and they're like well
that's what you got you're just going
around White's planing and right white
male privilege and man splint and it's
like where's your humanity now all of
those people have rediscovered Otto
because now they're all like why is
Trump sitting down with them the guy who
murdered otto warmbier of course said oh
but you didn't care whatever will happen
for their right whatever works but when
I see Trump with that I'm like guys this
guy is a guy with authoritarian impulses
he is a kleptocrat he's got his family
in positions of power I mean [ __ ]
Ivanka and Jared it's day and kousei
Hussein in there running around moral
Agha
yeah she's running around Europe trying
to get in like a coffee clutch with like
Merkel and Teresa may she's like get
here buddy here's here's what we think
they're like who's this [ __ ] right
who's this [ __ ] okay
he's so when I see this stuff going
crazy in the streets I'm like we we
could slide very easy into fascism real
fascism
you know the boot people this country
would learn to love the boot they would
love the boot on their neck because if
this [ __ ] keeps happening
a guy like Trump Trump is is empowered
by all of the stuff like when when these
people go on a taciturn
because Trump appeals to a few groups of
people but one of them they're people
that want to be kept safe right
from immigrants from criminals from
whoever so when Trump goes hey hey we're
gonna secure this country but here's how
we're gonna do it we're gonna take the
boot and step on your face there's a lot
of people whose country that it'll sing
god bless america
while it and they can card everyone off
to camp they don't care there's people
out there that don't care that the kids
are in a concentration comes talk about
the other night I'm like this can't be
the best way mm-hmm put him in a
Marriott do you know I was in st. Louis
there's hotel after hotel no one's
staying in them and the people that are
won't notice put them there right put
them in st. Louis they'll leave and I
start team believe st. Louis yeah I mean
there's got to be a better ways it's not
a good way it wasn't good when Obama did
it it's not good this is a problem but
people don't seem to understand why a
guy like Trump when when he came out
were you like were you one of these
people who were like oh he could never
win or well what did you think about him
when he came out yeah that he could
never win at the beginning yeah here in
LA elitist yes yeah yeah that's mostly
why you know and you're and you go out
with a Muslim woman yes I do I do I'm
dating a Muslim woman so do that what
you will folks by who's got a very white
name I know it's not the whitest name
yeah she's got like a world war two
nurse name it's the craziest thing and
so I'm not gonna say her name but it's
almost like Doris yeah yeah it doesn't
make any it's like meat my Iranian
friend Doris what the [ __ ] is this man
is she [ __ ] assimilating huh
yeah yeah meet my Persian friend what's
her name Mary Sue what but like I could
see very easily us just
right going right into fascism and and
and what's scary about that is it a lot
of people's country don't give a [ __ ] so
I don't I'm not one of these people that
don't I do think there's major concerns
but I don't think smacking up an demon
to go or no or however you say his name
is the way the yeah yeah I don't think
beating up people that right like you
know BuzzFeed owner should be easy to
beat Trump you just need an adult
you just need an adult that goes guys
the people that are really supporting
Trump are like people that are
live-streaming from their basement right
and talking about Flat Earth yeah and
that the moon is a spaceship that's a
huge contingent of his base and you
can't beat them you've forgotten how to
beat them I mean it's great it's like a
kid who's taken over the house at nine
years old yeah who's like the parents
don't know what to do yeah they're like
what are we gonna do it's like I don't
know cut is why fight lock them in the
room it's not a these aren't great
political thinkers yeah it should be
away yeah to beat beats it's not with
these random acts of violence that had
then make people think Oh Trump is like
the savior I was thinking about like I
was I was I watch that documentary on
Netflix the UM the Trump did you see the
Trump documentary and it's all about him
in New York City in the 70s 80s and 90s
and really yes he's really great yeah
any at the end of it and it leaves off
right like the last line of it is he's
like they're all laughing they won't be
laughing if I'm president yeah and then
it's boom but the last part of it is the
apprentice and you realize how much
reality television is deeply affected
our entire culture because it was one of
the first things that people
instinctively knew was fake but they
didn't care like they knew that it
wasn't real
that it was completely manufactured
reality but they enjoyed it and
emotionally invested in it as if it were
real right and it was wild the original
fake news
the original fake news I mean it was
wild walk cuz people knew some shows
were better at hiding it than others
like the raw competition shows I think
had more elements of things that were
actually real right yeah but even there
there were things happening behind the
scenes but then you got to like these
Real Housewives shows that are all
essentially almost scripted like these
people are put in situations the
outcomes are somewhat predetermined they
want certain things to happen right and
people don't care they still watch them
yeah they still just go okay you know
right yeah and so it was that and then
when you look at social media those are
the two biggest forces that have changed
culture in my lifetime like I haven't
seen I'm talking about just changing the
way that people act the way that they
relate to each other the way that they
consume like process information on
reality TV social media he's the monster
that combines both of those things yeah
and he becomes his unbeatable force yeah
he just doesn't play fair which was like
perfect yeah well it's not only did he
he doesn't play fair but it's also like
you can't beat him on his turf